Caitlyn Jenner admits that she's a way more interesting than Bruce ever was to be honest we the media through old Bruce right out the door he was gone okay this Caitlyn characters a lot more interesting and I knew from that point on I had to live my life as Caitlyn that's the biggest victory of all to wake up in the morning and just be yourself that's Caitlyn in a new campaign for H&M the I am Cait star is the new face of the brand's at sports line she also opened up to et about the impact of her journey back in May I thought what have we accomplished with that and then Vanity Fair and then the show and all that sort of stuff what we did is we opened up the conversation and for the last year not about you but it's been the most amazing year of people coming up and talking about this issue and it's been great that really husband